in tonight's democracy 20/20 report Joe
Biden says he is concerned President
Trump will try to steal the November
election or refused to leave the White
House if he loses the Trump campaign
says the presumptive Democratic nominees
trafficking and conspiracy theories
correspondent Peter Doocy has details
from Philadelphia where Biden made a
rare public appearance today Joe Biden's
visit to the City of Brotherly Love
included a roundtable discussion in the
building where dick Clarke used to
broadcast American Bandstand
I could never dance with two young and
know anything about American comedy show
Biden was far more serious my greatest
concern my single greatest concern this
pres is going to try to steal this
election Trump used that same language
talking voter fraud fears in 2016 we
don't want this election stolen from us
Trump's critics insisted those claims
were unfounded and four years later
Biden's worry involves doubts about mail
ballots this is a guy who said that all
mail-in ballots are fraudulent and he's
going so far to suggest that if Trump
loses he may not leave the White House
willingly you have so many rank-and-file
military personnel saying whoa we're not
a military state this is not who we are
I promise you I'm absolutely convinced
they will escort him from the White
House in a version with great dispatch
maybe different claim this spring that
the president may move the election
which quickly hit a dead end in the Rose
Garden I never even thought of changing
the date of the election why would I do
that November 3rd it's a good number no
I look forward to that election and
death that was just made-up propaganda
so the election is on and Biden is doing
his part to prevent Democratic
defections the idea that somehow I've
been told all along how young people
don't think that I'm in the right spot
right place there is no polling evidence
to sustain that nor is their voting
evidence thus far to sustain that the
list of possible Biden running mates may
be narrowing because we know the vetting
committee reached out to some women last
month but now one woman who has publicly
pushed herself as a good fit for the job
says she hasn't gotten any calls about
that Stacey Abrams Bret
Peter thank you